[Music]
welcome back loose skin is a problem for
many of us but we now have a
non-invasive solution here is brittany
from the jazzy wellness to tell us more
hey brittany
so what is an ultrasound skin lift
so we use a focused ultrasound so it
doesn't
penetrate the skin whatsoever it goes
all the way down to the muscle and lifts
and tightens
so how exactly does it work is it heat
how is it working on the skin
it promotes stimulation of the collagen
so your own body starts to
produce collagen once again so we're
anti-aging basically we're reversing
your aging
all right let's talk about the areas
that it treats we know that is it sheet
of turkey neck or we got some loose skin
up here what areas does it treat it does
the whole neck the whole face or any
body we're looking at the before and
after photos right here so
something like that how does this
compare to other procedures that are out
there
so this one it does take a few months
for the results but it's completely
natural and the results last up to five
years
wow so talking about the actual process
what does it feel like when you go in
for the procedure
it feels like a warm rubber band you
mostly just feel a tingly warm feeling
but it's
pretty easy so you go in you have a
treatment done do we get a consultation
first
how does it work you sit down with
someone that's coming in uh do you do a
consultation we go right in
for the actual uh ultrasound yeah we
like to do a consultation first because
we want to see exactly what your
concerns are what areas you want to do
if there's another treatment we think
would work better for you or any of that
sort
so someone comes in they get this done
when are we going to start seeing the
results you said within a couple weeks
we'll start seeing results on our skin
so same day we should see a textural
improvement so fine lines are gone or
some deep wrinkles are a little less
deep
but then over the next six months your
skin gets tighter and tighter and
tighter
i like it because it's a gradual you're
not going to show up to work the next
day and people were like hey there's
something different about you
this is kind of a gradual process and
you're going to start looking younger
and better are there any other
advantages that it has
it's just a one-time treatment what so
you can't beat that
one and done so so brittany you always
have a special when we talk to you
what special do you have for us today so
the first 10 callers will get a free
consultation
and 40 off of their treatment love it
appreciate it so much thank you brittany
for joining us thank you for having me
so the jazzy wellness is located at 900
south valley view
suite 100 you can find them online at
thejazzywellness.com
and take advantage of this special the
first 10 callers receive
40 percent off non-surgical facelift las
vegas now will be